bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur un
rt france comment décririez vous la
situation en ce moment à munich là où
vous exercez bonjour d'ailleurs je
trouve la situation est très dangereuse
vu le passé en été on a eu presque pas
de nouveau cas de corona là ça mon expo
exponentiellement et on n'a pas les
mêmes chiffres que la plupart des autres
pays en europe l'italie la france
l'espagne et cetera mais pour
l'allemagne c'est très alarmant et si ça
continue comme ça on va avoir les mêmes
problèmes que les autres pays
est-ce que la situation vous semble plus
grave qu'un l'aube de la première vague
ou en mars et les plus graves dans la
mesure que les gens ils n'ont pas la
même discipline ils ont plus tellement
peur comme la première vague et malgré
les moyens de prévention et de
traitement
on a une situation qui dépasse a pu la
première bague déjà ce que vous vous
l'expliquer il n'ya plus d'adhésion de
la part de la population plus envie de
jouer le jeu de du respect des
restrictions sanitaires des gestes
barrières
oui exactement les gens ils ont roma
après un thé le temps déjà des
restrictions plus de vacances +2 fait
plus de cinéma et cetera
on peut tolérer ça avec beaucoup de peur
dans les dos pendant quelques semaines
mais a pris les gens qui veulent plus
l'allemagne attendait record de
contamination
quelle est aujourd'hui la situation
dans les hôpitaux notamment dans les
services de réanimation
s'il n'y a pas des problèmes parce que
bien sûr d'abord c'est l'infection après
c'est éventuellement les traitements à
la maison et seulement deux trois
semaines après il ya des complications
monial traitement à l'hôpital il ya une
année passion on va voir comment ça va
se passer en novembre là on peut
absolument rien dire comment ça va se
développer
alors comment est ce que vous voyez quel
regard est ce que vous portez sur la
gestion de cette crise par les autorités
bon bien sûr les autorités ils n'ont pas
l'habitude de gérer des choses comme ça
y'a pas mal des choses qui sont logiques
qui sont très bien d'autres qui sont
plutôt mauvais en général je dirais y a
trop de restrictions et pas assez de
motivation pour les gens les gens ils
sont pris un peu comme deux des élèves
ont dit vous avez vous êtes obligé de
faire ça vous avez à éviter ça voudrait
mieux expliquer et dire aux gens vous
avez une responsabilité réfléchissez et
agissez à propos merci d'avoir prétendre
agir sur la trentaine de voix je vous
donne tant beernaert je rappelle que
vous êtes un médecin généraliste à
munich